how do you de-age somebody's face what's
the technique that goes into it that's
just all against blue screen and it's so
effective the lightning flashes going on
is actually hitting him there that
couldn't have been in the original yeah
catching the brick that was like
originally not a brick wait really
I would say that that secret did not
leak I'm
big thanks to raycon for sponsoring
today's episode Stick Around to the end
to see how you can get 15 off your
purchase of Premium everyday earbuds
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
we are joined today by Kelly Port an
amazing artist a supervisor he's worked
on a bunch of amazing films Kelly can
you tell us a little bit about yourself
I started 29 years ago with digital
domain Strange Days was my first film
worked on Apollo 13 Fifth Element
Titanic and most recently been on a
Disney Marvel kick with Beauty and the
Beast Maleficent Avengers Infinity War
Avengers end game and then most recently
Spider-Man No Way Helm as the production
side supervisor yeah but have you worked
any like big films
on my last three films if you look at
gross worldwide box office their numbers
one two and three are my last three
films which is pretty crazy so do you
get any sleep I don't get any sleep and
I don't get any of that box office
so you're a visual effects artist got it
dude I remember seeing this shot where
they're both flying through the city and
it's like okay Zendaya's face is
obviously real there but nothing else I
imagine Is Real at all what's so fun
about that they used something similar
in Far From Home this technique that was
just crazy simple John Watts I think
came up with it but it was just this fun
sort of doggy cam style where they're
kind of on bungee wires and getting
pulled by stunt guys you know left and
right and tugged this way left and right
and he would try to use his arms as he's
webbing and then they would try to kind
of do that in sync and then they had a
giant you know fan blowing on her and
then her face is just so perfect like
she looks terrified yeah and really
that's just all against blue screen and
it's so effective and it's so simple too
some of the challenge comes in is
putting that virtual camera through that
Virtual City because all that stuff
behind them you know we can't shoot
drones there's restrictions on shooting
drones within the city what's
interesting is like trying to find those
angles trying to find the Arc of the
swing and so typically the guys would
animate a swing and find that Arc and
then put that virtual camera behind that
something I know
the lighting so if you're swing you're
swinging through a city like this the
direction of the Sun is going to change
relative to the angle of this chest
mounted camera but also I'm noticing
Shadows quickly flying over her head
there so was that done on set with like
Flags blocking the light just really
quickly and you're having to match that
or is that a Digital Shadow it's a
little bit of both but it's primarily in
camera so what you want to do is have a
consistent Sun angle and then just block
it you know okay to get that sort of
tempo we would do camera tests about
like how frequent we thought that would
be and this just felt right so if it was
too rapid it would look weird if it
wasn't rapid enough it would look weird
so it's like finding that Goldilocks
sort of Rhythm I do see one thing here
which is like a nightmare for me which
is motion blurred curly hair that's
frizzy on a blue or green screen so how
the heck did you do that how did you key
your hair like make it look so clean
it's like all over the place it's moving
it's frizzy but this one was a little
bit harder because the camera was so
active and it's one of those screens
where you saw a little bit of the back
wall you saw a little bit of things like
blocking the lights and then you saw
some painted very dirty blue floor that
people have been walking on so it makes
it even more challenging when you have
those kind of things so now you're
having to actually create mats from
rotoscoping one of the tricks that I've
learned what you can do is take
alternate takes even sometimes the same
take where the camera is relatively
locked off where you can really pull a
nice good key and you can take just
flying hair you stabilize that and then
you track that onto her oh my goodness
so it's her hair being tracked onto her
but it's not her hair at that moment
it's from like some other piece wow I am
your hair from the future yeah
that's really clever
so you know they have Tom Holland in the
actual Spider-Man suit on set but you
end up replacing the suit to make it
unify everything together later on how
much of that suit is real versus CG in
this particular case it's mostly real
okay
um good looking suit then it's very
perfect right like it's very smooth and
you want to see the muscles you don't
want to see stitching or too bad or
wrinkles yeah so sometimes that's
traditional 2D kinds of cleanup
sometimes it's easier given the
circumstances to just render and light a
CG suit in there to help with that
cleanup process Peter he may have dodged
your legal troubles but things will get
much worse
with Murdoch here and catching the brick
that was like originally not a brick
wait really yeah wait
wait it was a snow globe a snow globe
yeah so that's one of those creative
decisions that came after the fact so
that shot where Tom Holland grabs the
brick away from Daredevil there he's
actually grabbing a snow globe so are
those CG fingers on his hand you can see
it's more of a sphere shape yeah I guess
he does kind of like grab like the sides
of the brick with his two fingers
yeah and same thing with Murdoch there
at the beginning like so he grabs the
brick there and he has it there so but
you can kind of by the shape of his palm
that he's actually grabbing something
more spherical especially with Tom
Holland there with his hands out like in
a sphere shape like this as opposed to
like brick shape I had no idea about
that that's fascinating yeah it's one of
those things like you don't necessarily
pick up on and hopefully not but I mean
they're invisible yeah that's the point
yeah and all these invisible effects the
thing that always gets me is that
they're not filmed like effect shots
they're filmed like normal shots where
you have the extras the set or the
locations locked down and the fact that
the cinematography doesn't change is
kind of what keeps those shots from
being triggered in my mind as visual
effect shots I just see them as normal
shots yeah and that's what you want yeah
you don't want to be taken out of the
movie that's the worst thing I mean this
is why I love visual effects just in
general is it just it never gets boring
it's always evolving the projects are
different the people the teams it always
keeps it fresh and fun I always
donating interesting things so leave a
comment down below with what you think
is the coolest fun fact of a visual
effect in a movie and maybe we'll
explain why
hello Peter so there's a lot of talk
about de-aging it's been a thing in
visual effects now for like 15 20 years
I feel like how do you de-age somebody's
face what's the technique that goes into
it it's a bunch of different techniques
some Studios have sort of a deep fake
type of technique it's a lot of
proprietary facial tracking that goes
into it and then they essentially just
track that on and have to re-light it
but it's also kind of pushing tucking
and pulling it's all these sort of
characteristics that happen as a human
being ages and those are the things that
you just basically have to now correct
for and you can over correct for it and
they start to look too young or too
different and so we tried to do our best
to keep it pretty subtle but just have
it ring more towards what he looked like
in that previous film it really seems
like de-aging is a catch-all term for
like 10 different actual techniques
happening like sometimes it's a straight
up 3D model sometimes you're just doing
a little bit of warping to 2D footage
sometimes it's texture work that's like
tracked onto the face sometimes it's AI
based stuff but it seems like really
it's a whole bunch of different
techniques all being applied in
different ways to achieve ideally the
same goal and just really depends on the
shot that you're doing yeah and I don't
think there's really any one technique
that's better necessarily I think it's
just different approaches to solve the
same problem
[Music]
this was so great when Toby and Andrew
and Tom were all there because it was
pretty obviously as you can imagine very
hush-hush and it was just such a great
vibe to have them all there definitely
the set was a buzz this is obviously an
incredibly major secret and I would say
that for I mean except for this shot
this shot got out there uh we made a
video about it but like this was a
successfully kept secret like no one
actually knew for fact that these two
are in it let alone in it as much as
they were what are some of the problems
involved with trying to keep such an
important secret it's just thousands of
people like our visual effects team is
by far the biggest team there is and
often the leaks don't necessarily come
from visual effects in this case I think
they did or an outsourced vendor I think
where it really came from I think the
main thing that keeps people from doing
it is like they're just gonna lose their
job yeah like forever as a studio when
Marvel Sony sends over a sequence to a
visual effects Studio to Begin work we
call that a turnover and then when they
get that it's usually sent as a sequence
and your name is like watermarked across
the whole thing so either the visual
effects producer or the name of the
studio that's sort of the preventative
medicine I guess you're not Peter Parker
one of the final trailers of this movie
to drop had like Spider-Man going up
against the Sandman the lizard Electro
all like this climactic shot and then it
ends and it's like oh man I'm so hyped
for the movie but I guess in was it
Brazil that shot in that trailer was
extended another like 15 frames or so
like a half second and it was just
enough to show the lizard there get hit
by a ghost yep
obviously we're seeing these shots that
are different from the final thing but
it's not just simply a matter of like oh
we just turned off the Spider-Man layer
are these shots created specifically for
the trailers yes what all is involved
with having to make that happen so we
literally just remember move them from
the renders and if there's Shadows we
have to you know account for those so
they just remove the the Andrew and Toby
layers so it kind
of a little bit of just straight up
turning off the layer yeah all right all
right I find it really interesting that
there's a lot of visual effects work
being done just for the marketing
purposes rather than the final product
sometimes you also see it's the same
shot like it's a similar shot from the
movie but it's a different take I'm
Peter by the way Doctor Strange oh using
your made-up names I'm Peter by the way
Doctor Strange oh here's your made-up
names that happens sometimes too but
yeah sometimes there's a trailer only
shot it's just additional extra material
that's fun to see that you wouldn't
necessarily see in the film Fair Point
yeah
it was really cool to just to not only
see the three Spiderman character
finally come together that was very
cathartic but also to have all of these
villains from the previous movies come
back together but I also noticed that
lizard and Sandman here are basically in
their CG versions the whole time but we
only see small little clips of them as
their real people did they film anything
for this they did not we didn't really
have access to reciphons or Thomas
hidden church so we actually ended up
using footage from the previous films
and manipulating it so reciphons when
he's healing we actually used an outtake
and that was shot on film scanned at
high resolution tracked body tracked
everything like yeah so ultimately ended
up being a lot of that CG especially for
Thomas Hayden Church when he's
transforming we had to manipulate it to
get him into the scene lighting wise and
all sorts of things like that but you're
still using the footage as kind of like
a base texture
okay sure because I noticed like he's
got sand porn down his face so obviously
you had to have had like a 3D model of
his face remade and matched in so that
you can have that new particle Sim of
sand falling down yeah the lightning
flashes going on is actually hitting him
there that couldn't have been in the
original movie yeah and we have the 3D
model of him and like you said we had to
have that for the sand simulation anyway
so you can also use that as a way to
manipulate the lighting as well so that
chart there is that a full 3d model or
is that footage of him that you guys are
kind of manipulating
three yeah okay wow yeah
where's the Box Peter with no way home
we had an opportunity to see what's
effectively a full CG character realize
that a different era with VFX technology
so we had Sandman back with Spider-Man 3
and it was a pretty big deal to have
grain simulations and that many
particles on screen at the same time and
then you guys Revisited Sandman here how
did the technology change between those
two films with almost a decade and a
half if not two decades between them
certainly technology has changed in a
big way more effective simulations the
power to compute more is certainly
improved in 10 years dramatically
ultimately in some of these big
simulations they were like 300 million
particles or something like that it's
like really crazy that's a lot but
they're big simulations and Chris Wagner
of image Works would remind me of that
all the time like if I had notes it's
like okay just reminding you that these
are very nice simulations but I feel
like that's also very reasonable it's
like you have like this whole sequence
took hours if not days and so many
gigabytes or terabytes to simulate all
this stuff and then it's like well I
wanted this one little thing in this one
corner here to be different but in order
to make that change you have to redo it
all yeah that's how simulations work
yeah you use what you have so in that
sense nothing has changed in 10 years
like what really has changed is the
ability to iterate more but because yes
you can iterate more but you're
iterating with more so you're always
pushing that technology to its Breaking
Point gotcha so as technology gets
better you're just turning up the number
of particles and it still takes the same
amount of time
yeah that's really funny if you think
Spider-Man is shooting web out of his
wrist naturally is the way it should be
subscribe if you think shooting it with
machines that Tony Stark made for him is
the way it should be hit the
notification Bell
hello everybody and welcome back to the
Brandy o'daniels segment courtesy of
today's sponsor raycon now if you're
already looking to click away let me
tell you something this show would not
be possible but for the sponsors and
also of course you the Beloved viewer
and you know of course us the content
creator but you know look it's like a
trifecta okay it's a trinity of
perfection and we all hold hands and
Skip merrily through life's Meadows to
allow this show to be possible because
if it wasn't for you the viewer and if
it wasn't for the sponsor and it wasn't
for us the content creator this episode
wouldn't exist at all and that's just a
shame but you know what's even more of a
shame paying full price for premium
earbuds well that's a thing of the Past
come on guys with raycon you can get
premium audio for half the price as any
other premium Wireless earbud out there
now how do they do this well it's
actually quite simple raycon prioritizes
the quality and the consumer first and
foremost you see raycon optimizes their
earbuds with gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit now we think that's very
important because if you're going to
wear these things every day whether it's
to the gym to work to the office on your
commute wherever however you need them
they're going to fit in your ears and
not fall out we've done extensive
experimentation and these earbuds they
won't budge and in addition to that they
have over eight hours of play time with
a 32 hour battery life so these things
are going to go all day and have you
sounding and feeling great and if you
don't believe me well guess what raycon
earbuds have over 48 000 five-star
reviews and if that doesn't say quality
then I don't know what does anymore so
go on and hop skip and jump merely with
us over here at Corridor to buy
iraacon.com Corridor crew to get 15 off
your purchase that's 15 off your
purchase by going to buy raycon.com
Corridor proof once again huge thanks to
raycon for sponsoring and now let's get
back to the episode
thank you so much for watching Kelly
thank you so much for coming on the
couch with us I enjoyed everything
you've told us today I learned a lot and
I had a lot of fascinating insights to
these movies so thank you seriously I
really appreciate the time you spent for
us thank you it's great being here also
we have extended reacts on our website
Corridor digital.com where it's a little
less cut down you get to hear a bit more
of Kelly and our take on things
quarterdigital.com and I will see you
guys either tomorrow or our Sunday video
or next Saturday if for some reason you
don't watch the Sunday videos all right
see you then